space pirates make a surprise but
welcome return to the world of Star Wars
in the season 3 premiere of the
Mandalorian but something is very
different about these dastardly foes
the premiere of the Mandalorian season 3
kicks off the next chapter of din
jaron's story with a bang as he and
grogu land on the planet of Concordia to
seek audience with the armorer and
battle a colossal alien monster along
the way branded in apostates by the
heretical Mandalorian cult Children of
the watch Jaron pleads with the armorer
for forgiveness and learns that he must
bathe in the Living Waters below
Mandalore to erase his past
transgressions
this is the way
from there Jaron and grogu set off to
visit some old friends as they prepare
for the desolate Wasteland that was once
Mandalore the duo set off for the Outer
Rim planet of Navarro to speak with
grief karga the leader of the Bounty
Hunter's Guild and new high magistrate
of Navarro they discover that karga has
transformed the planet from a criminal
hotspot into a booming Hub of trade and
Industry unfortunately jaron's visit is
cut short by the untimely arrival of
pirates on kargus doorstep who don't
seem too thrilled about the New
Direction the borrow is taken karga
defeats the pirate leader vayne in a
duel then karga tells vayne to alert
Captain Dorian Shard about Navarro's
latest developments but who exactly are
these Pirates and who is Gory and shark
fans of Star Wars the Clone Wars know
that space pirates played a significant
role during the Clone Wars specifically
the weak way Pirates led by fan favorite
scoundrel Hondo onaka Who Bore the title
of pirate king on Florham and often
found him self at odds with Anakin
Skywalker and Obi-Wan Kenobi despite his
criminal background onaka would
eventually become something of an
anti-hero forming a tenuous alliance
with the galactic Republic and later
helping The Fugitive Ezra Bridger during
Star Wars Rebels although several of the
Pirates accompanying vain appeared to be
weak way it's worth mentioning that
onaka's rule as pirate king came to an
end when the Confederacy shattered his
face on Florham this is significant now
that gorian Shard seems to have claimed
that title for himself vayne later
returns in the episode when he and his
cronies Tracked Down din Jaron and
battle him through an asteroid field
eventually forcing him into the path of
the pirate king gorion Shard and his
immense Cruiser we get our first look at
Shard when he radios jaron's ship and
tells the Bounty Hunter to come quietly
the pirate king appears to be an
entirely new species of alien in the
Star Wars Universe a hulking humanoid
whose Mossy beard and reptilian face
make him look like an Intergalactic
counterpart to Swamp Thing the fact that
gorian Shard seems to have taken over
from the legendary Hondo onaka as pirate
king is extremely telling of his status
among the Pirates though even more
interesting is that his crew seems to be
made up of a swarm of different alien
species not just weak way the way Jaron
and the Pirates speak about Shard
implies that he's become a significant
power in the galactic underworld perhaps
even surpassing the strength of onaka
it's also abundantly clear that Shard
and his Pirates now have their sights
set on jarn kid
never trusts a pirate though it remains
to be seen how the mysterious character
managed to claim the title of pirate
king and how his story might intertwine
with that of Hondo onaka the return of
these space pirates ought to have plenty
of Clone Wars fans wondering if onaka
himself might make a surprise appearance
during season 3 of the Mandalorian
foreign